everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm everyone loves good chess
sacrifice i thought what better video to
make then in my opinion some of the
greatest sacrifices of all time so i've
never the list down to five and so i
hope you guys enjoy this first video
we're going to be looking at it comes
from the game of the century many all
may be familiar with it
bobby fischer playing the black pieces
at this particular time was thirteen
years old just kind of coming on to the
scene wasn't really a household name
this game definitely got him on the map
his opponent is donald byrd playing the
white pieces donald bird just the
previous year had won the US Open
Championship so an extremely talented
player but if we look in it just kind of
setting it up we have the Queen coming
here the Queen under attack here on the
eighth Queen coming here to b6 and then
white getting his Bishop involved to c4
the knight coming here to c3 we have the
Bishop to c5 after the rook swings over
here to e7
we now have the Keane come over here to
f1 and in this particular case now is
where the sacrifice comes in so I'm
actually going to pause and let you guys
think about the game and what you would
do in blacks point of view you can look
at it his queen is under attack here on
b6 definitely wants to make sure that he
just doesn't give that up if we kind of
look at it he has you know this rook
over here on a e8 it's not really doing
anything so if you were black
how would you continue in this
particular case a Bobby Fischer decided
to go ahead and play the crazy move of
Bishop here to e6 sacrificing his queen
here on b6 and after the bishop takes on
b6 we have one of the greatest King
chases that's ever happened so the
bishop takes here on c4 check the king
is forced to move over here on G one
very important than this rook on EI to
just eyes down on this efile the king is
forced to or after the knight comes to
e2 the king is forced to move back this
Knight can just continue to gobble up
pieces we have a discovered attack here
every time so the King has to come back
we have the same thing now the knight
comes back here to c3
King comes back again since he's being
attacked and now we have the pawn taking
the bishop here in b6 also a discovered
attack on the Queen the Queen is forced
to move after Queen B for we have the
rook swing down to a4 not only attacking
the Queen but also protecting the bishop
here on c4 and then after the Queen
takes here on b6 we have the knight take
here on the one and Bobby Fischer later
on would go on to win this game if we
look at it I'll go and continue the game
here in a minute
but if we look at it Bobby Fischer gave
up his queen and in return he got a rook
he got a couple minor pieces he got a
pawn and really he just was able to just
dominate the rest of the game we have
the rook over here in the h1 corner not
really doing anything Bobby Fischer more
than anyone really knew how to utilize
all this pieces together and if you look
at from why it's really hard to
recognize that this Queen here on b6 is
not just going to be taken and you're
going to have a really good game for
white so we'll go ahead and continue
just so you can see the rest of the game
not going to give too much commentary on
it just because there's another video on
the game of the century if you want to
watch it but we'll kind of go through
the moves right here and then after we
have the King come down to d1 then
there's actually a force mate from Bobby
Fischer and so we just kind of brought
the King over and eventually it was
checkmate so this is game number five
and our best sacrifices of all time
number four on our list comes back from
1911 we have white played by Ed Lasker
international master and then black lead
played by George Thomas also
international master the game was
actually pretty short there's not very
many moves we have to go through before
we actually get to the sacrifice itself
also again do you want to give an
opportunity to y'all to kind of think
about what should white do in this
particular case and it would be kind of
crazy if you came up with it and found
the entire line but why decided to play
Queen takes here on h7 and what's really
cool about the sacrifice not only is
white giving up the Queen but the rest
of the game is four so the King can't
come here to f7 because of the night
right here
so he's forced to take and then the
night takes here on f6 double-checking
the king with both the knight and the
bishop that means the king has to move
there's no other way to get a bit out of
a double check the king is now forced to
move here to h6 he doesn't want to come
back here to h8 or it's going to
automatically be checkmate right there
so again decides to come back here and
play h6 and then we have the Knight to
g4 again everything is forced this
Bishop right here on d3 is crucial this
King can no longer retreat so the king
is forced to come here to g5 he comes to
g5 we have h4 again just pushing this
King down further and further we have
pawn here to g3 King f3 the bishop now
again all these Knights the minor pieces
the pawns all playing together the King
comes back here and then after the rook
over here to h2 the King decides to
resign if the King were to come here to
g1 then Y could go ahead and castle on
the Queen side and it would be checkmate
so black decided he was going to resign
right at the very end before white could
actually have the checkmate but
brilliant brilliant move by Ed Lasker to
actually see so far in advance all the
different force moves bringing the King
all the way from the eighth rank all the
way down here to the first rank giving
up a clean and just using all the minor
pieces get you on the top five list of
the chess websites all-time greatest
sacrifices number three and our list
comes back from 1928 why it's going to
be played by links burg black is going
to be played by miguel knight Dorf
obviously has his own variation in the
Sicilian defense so very very strong
player this particular case so white is
under attack so he plays his King here
to g2 and it's blacks move so take a
minute think about what you would do if
you were black see if you can find the
best move and black actually played the
move Bishop here - do you want
sacrificing one of his minor pieces to
continue the attack on the King so after
the Knight takes here on g1
the Queen swings down to h2 not many
places for the King to move so he comes
over here to f3 then the palm pushes
forward to e5 threatening just to come
down with this pawn and then after the
take it would be checkmate right there
so the pawn takes the knight recaptures
checking the King giving up a second
minor piece of material now we have the
knight taking here on e5 check the King
comes up here to ef4 Knight check again
after the King comes back now pawn
pushes forward to f4 threatening both we
have check here checkmate actually with
Knight here to e5 and we also have the
potent attack of Bishop here to g4 why
decides to go ahead and take with his
pawn and then the bishop comes here to
d4 potent attack that we talking about
why it does have the option of just
moving and losing his Queen right away
in this particular game decided to go
ahead and take this material again
didn't quite see the 7 to 10 moves in
advance that night or flus and then
after the knight comes here to e5 check
after the pawn takes then pawn over here
to h5 and checkmate what's really cool
about this game is black managed to
sacrifice all four of his minor pieces
even those pieces that weren't even
closely related to involved into the
action managed to sacrifice all of them
for a checkmate later on to the game so
extremely extremely good game really
really cool to have a very interesting
way to sacrifice the bishop early on
just to have an attack on your
opponent's king always definitely fun to
watch and earned your spot as number
three on the chest website com greatest
sacrifices of all time the materialist
comes back to 1858 one of my all-time
favorite games in chess White's played
by none other than Paul Morphy in my
opinion the greatest attacking player of
all time really understood how to use
all this pieces together his opponent's
two guys not greatest chess players in
the world and they really found
themselves playing against a opponent
that was just way beyond
their skill set but these two opponents
are due Carl in court ice rod so in this
particular game white is just played in
black plays pawn here to be five White's
play by Paul Morphy so take a minute
just think about how you would continue
with this particular setup and Paul
Morphy started the attack with the
knight taking here on b5 recognizing
that didn't really need the night for
the attack
so sacrificed it then after the
sacrifice the bishop takes here on b5
then we have the knight stopping here on
d7 we have the castling gaining the
tempo with the attack here on the seven
black swings over and tries to give some
assistance with his rook here on d8 then
we have an exchange here giving up that
bet rook there on d7 for the Knights and
then after they take now we have the
rooks Wingo right here the knight the
rook can't move because it's pinned down
with the bishop right here so we have
the Queen trying to give some room for
the King to breathe a little bit so we
have the bishop take after the knight
takes then the Queen takes oh and after
the knight takes the Queen over here on
b8 then we have the rook swing in here
to d8 and checkmate so Paul Morphy
pretty much just giving up the majority
of his pieces because you really
understood with his bishop here on g5
all he needed was something back here on
d8 to win the checkmate so again Paul
Morphy one of my favorite players I'm a
little bit biased earned a spot as
number two on the all-time greatest
sacrifices list number one on our list
comes from 1934 it's the Peruvian
immortal why it's going to be played by
Esteban kunal a Peruvian grey Master
blacks gonna be played by an unknown
amateur what you're about to witness is
what happens when a Grandmaster plays a
chess amateur pretty much the goal for
the Grandmaster is how many pieces can
you sacrifice and embarrass your
opponent so we'll go ahead and get into
it the start of the game is pretty
normal and we'll get to our actual
position here in a second and after the
black King castles on the Queen side
white decides to play a very interesting
move so take a minute think about what
you would do if you are white in this
position and Esteban decided to play
pawn takes here on b4 sacrificing his
rook here on a1 so the Queen immediately
swoops down and takes here on a1 the
King has to move so after the King Tate
or comes here to d2 the Queen's going to
swing over starting just gobbling up
material right now after the Queen takes
white decides I gave up both of my rooks
now's a good time to give up my queen
so moves his Queen here to c6 black has
to take with this pawn back on c6 or and
then the bishop comes over here to a6
and checkmates the bishop here on f4 and
the bishop pair on a6 all that is needed
for whites to kill the King so white
decided to give up both of his Brooks
and his queen in three moves and still
checkmate his opponent so this lands you
spot on the all-time greatest sacrifices
as number one on our list just because I
think it's really incredible that
someone actually played pawn to b4 and
thought about that entire move order so
congratulations hope you guys enjoyed
again I like to do more videos like this
just because I think they're fun
especially if you just enjoy chess and
things like sacrifices sounds good to
see some of the old classic games and
some of the greatest games that have
ever been played so hopefully you guys
enjoyed and I'll see you on the next
video
thanks for watching